The temperature of our favorite time of year.
The sight of the landscape of the environment
we grew up in.
The taste of a home cooked meal.
The emotion of an old song that we once listened
to on repeat for a month straight.
All of these things elicit a feeling so unique
and powerful that it appears to transcend
time and space.
It brings us into a state of being that cannot
be described with anything other than just
this one word.
It is nostalgia.
Nostalgia is one of the most unique and valuable
capacities of the human mind.
It is the closest thing we have to time travel.
It gives us an opportunity to experience moments
of our life while being completely free from
our normal anxieties and uncertainties.
In general, every moment in life carries with
it a set of fears, anxieties, and stresses.
We are always concerned with making the next
moment perfect and we worry about what tomorrow
may or may not bring.
But nostalgia frees us from this.
When we experience nostalgia, we are given
an opportunity to feel a moment as it truly
was, void of any fear or uncertainty.
This is because the circumstances that we
were worried about at the time have already
past.
At the time, our worries lied in the uncertainty
of what the next several days, months, or
years would bring.
But those days have since past.
We have lived through the times that we were
worried about and here we are, doing just
fine.
Ironically, letting the state of nostalgia
carry us into the past can remind us of the
importance of appreciating the present.
It shows us that our desire to perfect all
the moments of life is foolish and unnecessary.
It shows us that our fears and worries regarding
the future are irrational and insignificant.
And it shows us that we are resilient and
adaptable and that no matter what life throws
at us, we can sustain and continue to create
meaningful positive moments.
Nostalgia provides clarity in that even the
moments that may have been stressful and did
not seem so good at the time, can still carry
a sense of great value and appreciation when
viewed through the lens of hindsight.
This very moment in time, despite if there
are things going on that may seem negative
or stressful, will likely still have a feeling
of nostalgia attached to it when you are reminded
of it in the future.
And if this is true, why not appreciate it
right now as well?